oh my God look at me it's a willly Wonka
review and I'm a monochromatic no life
no joy need a scarf for something
there Christmas in the Northwest ladies
and
[Music]
gentlemen so Wonka is directed by Paul
King who directed The Paddington movies
it's a remel SL prequel kind of tied to
the Gene Wilder movies but not 100%
because there are differences between
the two universes it's a story of a
young Willie Wonka talented in chocolate
not a penny in his pocket didn't mean
for that to rhyme but he is talented in
chocolate not a penny in his pocket but
he's going to rock it and then he'll
sock it to the chocolate cartel we're
going down a well going straight to hell
at the Ring of the Bell he gets hustled
into debt thus he's in servitude to work
off that debt with a bunch of people who
are also in the same boat does his main
motivation Wonka and his friends have
basically been enslaved in this laundry
mat so he wants to make enough money
from his chocolate to pay off their
debts and open his huge Chocolate
Factory which I won't lie when Wonka was
signing the contract didn't read the
fine print I was like oh the days of
those multi- Channel networks on YouTube
took me back not all joy but it did take
me back do people still sign on to those
real question have they gotten better do
they hustle you like before all right so
Timothy Shalom as a younger Willie Wonka
I thought he was great he has the
charismatic like ability you want from a
protagonist in this kind of a story also
from a younger version of the character
Willie wonky you can see how this young
talented Optimist might l become this
older talented recluse and like I said
like this this world of Wonka doesn't
feel like it's a one toone ratio of a
prequel to The Gan Wilder Willy Wonka
but the tie-in are definitely there Hugh
Grant plays an Ooma Loompa who looks
identical to the Gene Wilder Willy Wonka
Ooma Loompas the Oompa Loompa song some
of the other songs in the movie are
pulled straight from that version of
Willy Wonka in the Chocolate Factory
it's pulling what you need from a
beloved classic which is probably smart
to do when you stray too far fans don't
tend to like that though the songs in
the Tim Burton the Oompa Loompa songs in
the Tim Burton movie I believe I
remember them being more accurate they
were more in line from the songs from
the play my elementary school did back
in the day I can say that funny
observation don't want to compare the
two movies too much cuz they are just
not related but the Tim Burton Wily
Wonka was trying to bring joy a
childhood joy to people that he didn't
have in his childhood because of his
father Wonka in this movie is
nostalgically chased fa in the childhood
Joy he did have in his childhood because
of his mother two very different pasts
two very different Vibes I got to say I
like the optimistic version of this one
just a good time and it is a good time
undeniably this movie is made for kids
families yes but also kids like I've
said before there's a difference between
a movie that's made for families and
made for children I myself found the
movie it's like the phrase charmingly
delightful when people say charmingly
delightful I feel like this is the vibe
they're talking about and which some of
the jokes in the movie didn't land for
me but I couldn't help but think like if
my niece was watching this she would
probably be laughing but there is enough
to keep parents engaged also because
actually deals with heavy themes heavy
themes of Entrepreneurship corruption
trying to start a small business when
going up against Titans of business who
are all aligned against you and let's
face it the little guy going up against
corporate douchebags that would have
been enough that would have been enough
to get the audience to be like I'm on
that guy's side but that little guy
being a beloved character from all of
our childhoods I mean come on we're
rooting for Wonka in here there are
things in this movie my brain wants to
give a pass to that I usually wouldn't
give a pass to feels like it's me going
through pathetic amounts of cope but all
things not being equal these things that
would be misses and other movies did mix
better in here whether I say they're
okay or not the important thing is that
I just address them love or hate make of
it what you will as long as you're
informed my video wasn't completely
useless that would be the noticeable CGI
and the overuse of green screen in a
world this Fantastical I get it you
gotta but it was definitely noticeable
in here but for the visual aesthetic of
this
extraordinary almost cartoonish larger
than life kind of world it kind it mixed
better than when I watch other movies
and I'm like that CGI is very noticeable
also some of the acting from the side
characters I felt was meh sometimes it's
meh sometimes it feels like they're in a
play and they're projecting how actors
and plays project cuz the back row needs
to hear them like it almost feels like
Sesame Street like gee Big Bird what are
we going to do but I couldn't deny the
fun and family Magic the movie did have
in its presence the first two acts are
stronger than the third act the third
act has this whole Espionage element to
it I was like okay this feels very
different from the magic of the first
two act kind of overplayed its hand with
that element but when you feel the magic
of wily Wonka on screen that's when the
movie was at its strongest and I have
myself a good time no alcohol required
funny enough the last real solid memory
Wily Wonka has with his mother in this
movie is on a boat so does wiie Wonka
associate boat rides with the loss of
his mother thus boat rides in Wonka's
factory are nightmare fuel I don't know
possibly but that that does make sense
all right so Wonka have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to same
[Music]
more